hey guys have you ever wondered what it
would be like to look at something and
have influence over it have you ever
looked at your TV remote and just wanted
it to come towards you because I know I
have so when Toby got in touch with me
to ask us if we wanted to try out an eye
tracking device I was like hell yes okay
can't quite do the things that I just
said however it allows you to have a new
form of immersion while playing games
I'm going to check this out with a
couple of games today I'm going to play
shelter to for you let's try being a cat
with eye tracking immersion built in
first things first is to calibrate the
eye tracking and it was crazy how well
this actually worked and it's protocol
because once it works your computer
actually goes to sleep when you're not
looking at it so I thought that was a
pretty cool built-in functionality hmm
feel like I'm using the force or
something see just before we start I
just want to say that this weird blob
that you see going around the screen is
not normally part of the game that is
actually the Toby eye tracker telling me
that is seeing my eyes and it's crazy
it's really strange but we'll see what
kind of changes this makes apparently it
allows us to look at enemies and they
see us or something and interact with
our cubs and move the camera and all
sorts of things so this should be really
interesting mother lynx is pregnant and
searching for a den but the night is
cold and fearsome predators have caught
her scent
that's cool you can watch me reading
mites and delights
Katia alright moving in so parent if I
want to move the camera oh there you go
let's look at the different size oh
that's cool but I want to focus on my
little my little cat right shift + space
got it go oh shiz oh I just ran into
into something right okay let's go I can
do this and then space yeah
follow the bunny
hey
Oh
jump the stream
come on front of the bunny
it's space jump up oh that was great I
tell you what I'm thinking
that the end easy that night the stars
whispered to mother links okay didn't
know animals could talk two stars but
we'll go with it let's do this
I can't look up at the sky
so weird how it knows where another king
so strange I look at the constellations
I find myself constantly opening my eyes
mom because unconscious it's looking at
them looking at my eyes oh it's so
strange I don't even mean to be moving
the camera but because i'm looking at
all the constellations I can't help it
right follow the stars stars will show
us the way little pregnant kitty where
to ryans belt are these actual
constellations any any viewer really
good at constellations that can help me
out here cuz I'm not like it I just know
a ryan stuff oh oh no no
it's pretty pretty
shelter to
let's make pretty Browning's let's draw
a robot but a that's a terrible square
I'm not doing this right there hopefully
soon I'll give Braff to some Cubs and
then with my eyes I can speech them I
think
ah I like that one there the one that
you can see me looking at that's my
favorite the bright orange one so cured
I love the art style for this game it's
like patchwork everywhere
ah ah Kirk her as my favorite Vavi
soldier and Baba and you know I probably
said those names completely wrong we
gotta protect care shouldn't have
favorite should I whatever she ventures
into the vast open world a land full of
prey to feed her starving family who are
not yet strong enough to leave I didn't
read fast enough whatever I get a gist
they can't leave the rocks
so we gotta go find some student file
Bella's can I say hi to them come on
let's go see hi Hey oh okay whatever the
boring not do you think wait how many
are there there's only three no that's
cool yeah hello 30 feet right let's go
John oh okay you're gonna be stealthy
we're gonna get loads of food for little
babies why are we gonna go Oh heard
something did you hear that
where did there you are come back how am
I supposed to get that it's a little
bunny where did it go it's so white I
can hardly hot am I looking for bunnies
or am I looking for something a bit more
substantial because this bunny is on a
missions like I don't think I can I
don't think I can whoa oh my gosh it's
gone oh there is ah where is the fellow
the bunny oh I'm at bres oh nice music
why mushroom we found a mushroom not
quite meet rabbit meat but you know ill
do
I love them makes me feel so relaxed
let's get some more mushrooms are we not
hunting down robbers that we are
vegetarian I'm down with that well what
am i doing I think was first to do what
the flood did I just get one what's up
with that noise with oh my gosh she's in
my mouth I'm not vegetarian anymore gave
up didn't work DD DD did it did it
where's my Cubs Cubs I got your food
where are you I got you a rabbit
move fight over the rabbit ah it's
apparently if I look at them they all
say like knowledge me if I look away
they don't acknowledge me you're gonna
be out I think it's working great no
meows away and the meows no we are and
then we have meows I think it works I
don't know it could just be really
really good timing but are they are you
still too young to follow me around what
did I just do i right clicked and
something happened at the n is you're
down there oh look at all the bunnies ok
let's go down this way
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo I'm gonna get no
don't yes I'm getting good of this it's
nice for the eye gaze around cuz i can i
can say to you guys like hey did you see
that and you you're actually looking at
where I'm new here oh I think this is
the last rabbit Lucas in the music I'm
guessing maybe
come get your dinner ah yes look at a
solvent wait what was my favorite again
he was good for fair this one the orange
one we're all majestic and older I like
this hmm come on Cubs I turn around I
want to see them jump um okay Dorsia yet
ok let's go towards the snowflake
together little cups where are they I
gotta wait for you you're mine let's get
this money
I got to show them how to have a hunt be
good mother there's a flower can I eat
the flower it's huge flower that has a
massive flower it's bigger than them see
okay oh i just press see what okay so
there's little will sit symbols but I'm
looking out for something no idea
it's good love it
yeah whereas my Cubs where are they oh
my gosh don't scare me like that stay
close [ __ ] eat none on them hey save
some for the other two whether you're
the two gone you're going right huh I
never she looked at the funnies after oh
we can eat them remains okay and there's
a big flower here dude hey you guys you
need to eat as well you can't this
runaway
in the water my Cubs swim mouse left
okay let me swim oh you you're drinking
okay yeah they're just like headfirst
can you swim
don't say I just died I thought cats can
swim it just don't like the water very
much okay good I'm kind of thing we're
in a new season so are we progressing
can we progress what is this eggs let's
eat the eggs mouse right okay
eat this bread eggs this Baron is not
gonna be happy with us we just killed
its babies get out of here don't want to
have to explain what happened oh okay no
meaning eat the eggs guys I found us
more eggs eat it they're so greedy they
never saved me any
was this
cutscene no I'm still controlling
nothing yeah all right don't really know
what I'm doing or where I'm going in
this game but it's cute I'll give it
that
oh this is on the other side i'm on the
other side of the water now i'm going
towards the winter place
where are my cops I'm such a bad mother
okay there now
let's get this I'm gonna kill you
I can't do it too old for this it's
quite simplistic but I like that in
games Oh what's this jump wait there are
DNA by where oh they're right there okay
let's go i think i just missed our
chance though yeah we're already our
breath fantastic oh I can pick my Cubs
now and run with them I've got my
favorite one in my mouth okay that's
good cute gotta find some good pray for
us so we can feed okay I think my Cubs
are getting bored of rabbits and I don't
blame them it's nighttime do we need to
go home what can I just keep on going
because i want to keep on going
sunrise either over here
what what oh oh no oh no wait what where
is my cuffs why is it dark what's
happening where's my Cubs Cubs come in
come no i do i want i want my favorite
one I want to pick up my favorite one
don't want you this one go what are we
doing while these weird noises okay my
Cubs okay saw them eyes what you guys
are okay
what oh no oh no huh huh okay okay now
what's this does that mean wait ah we
only have three jobs we have fall before
live in terrible but I didn't even see
anything coming out for a slow is so
dark oh oh that's mortgage can we look
for him is he definitely gone oh well
oh okay let's just keep on moving get
some liquor okay no it's gonna preserve
my air no no no no no no no no no no no
yeah yes I'm so proud of myself there
you go cubs yup you deserve it you had
your sibling die today so we eat well
2mon all in all playing shelter to with
the Toby IX I tracker was pretty cool it
made it really a massive that I could
move the camera just by shifting my eyes
but it was also pretty hard to get used
to because I wasn't used to that so my
mouse will kind of fighting against my
eyes and I found the girls having a
little battle going on but once you got
into it it actually made things a lot
easier to move around I love that when
you look at your Cubs they actually talk
to you and that just brings a whole new
level of immersion I mean those little
things are so cute anyway especially
care if you think this is something that
appeals to you you can click on it in
the description below and there's a
special code guess what the code is guys
check my necks with this special code
you get thirty percent off so if that's
something that you are interested in
then definitely go check it out in the
description below also they seem to have
quite a good developer community around
this so you can develop using eye
tracking capabilities you're a developer
and you're into all that maybe check it
out it might be cool let me know in the
comments below what you think about this
I tracking device I think it's really
nice that people are racking on
alternative ways that people can play
games because it's just upsetting that
some people can't enjoy them to the
fullest but devices that this open the
door so everyone can enjoy even if they
might not been able to in the first
place and I think that's freaking
awesome if everyone should be able to
play games because games are cool I will
be doing another video soon with the eye
tracker playing a horror game so watch
out for that I'm looking forward to
playing it for you and have loved
everything hey
I didn't know I do that see I'm vérella
corporation oh go away I hate you
mannequins with a family what the bloody
house bill but why did he find me what